[Music]
we have time for one
question do you remember the hardest
time you've ever laughed it doesn't have
to be like a good story but just the
last time you were really just on the
ground crying
oh we don't screen questions
here no I
don't drink it now now it now I'm
[Applause]
you I wish I did though that's so sad no
no no watch we're going to build oh
follow the fear okay okay when's the
last time you
[Applause]
yourself do you want to
[Laughter]
know I was on the
[Applause]
I was driving to uh ntsf SD SUV a show
that was on Adult Swim that Paul Shear
yep uh one of our friend comedians uh
created
and I just I just rock some Dell
[Applause]
Taco and it was time it was time to let
just a little air out of
[Applause]
the a little air out of the tank yeah
and uh not so much
air Rob rle
[Music]
everybody